okay um one thing I forgot to say or we
forgot to say for sort of a commercial
interruption is as I go through this if
those of you watching the video would
like a chart of my six state structure
to follow along if you look down
underneath the video there should be a
link there that goes to some version of
my website story mastery comm if you
click that it'll link through so you can
find out how we will send you a free
copy of the chart that you can download
so you can just follow along with these
six stages if you like as we go through
them so they're free of charge isn't
that cool okay so I was leaving off at
the end of the first two stages the
setup and the new situation before we go
on to the hero's pursuit of this goal
though I want to talk a bit about the
inner journey for the character what I
mean by the inner journey is that while
the outer journey is a journey of
accomplishment it means that the plot
level of the movie at the surface level
is about a character who wants some
visible goal there's a visible finish
line that that character wants to cross
so in the case of a few good men he
wants to get them off of this murder
charge he wants to he starts out wanting
to get a good reduced sentence and then
it'll end up wanting to get an acquittal
so that's his goal and it's going to
carry us all the way from the beginning
of act 2 to the climax but if you go
deeper with the character to what I call
the inner journey it is a journey of
transformation and now we're talking
about how the character changes through
the course of the story it's a
transformation actually from living in
fear to living courageously and so in
stage 1 in the setup when you first meet
the hero one of the things you want to
notice is this hero will always be stuck
in some way well we the audience of the
reader will get a sense that there's
something that the character is just
tolerating they're not really living
fully they're not real living a
fulfilled life they're not being all
they can be
whew well and we can see when we meet
Kaffee that he's kind of there he's just
very flipping about things he's not
committed to anything we find out it's
sort of subtly presented at first but
his father was a great lawyer who became
the Attorney General of the United
States before he passed away
drops a little hint of something might
be going on more than just he's a
hotshot attorney but he is stuck in this
way that's going to be the first
indication of his arc his transformation
now to understand how the transformation
for a character works you need to ask
yourself a few things about the
character and the first of those is what
is the character's wound how is this
character wounded in the past a wound
could be a painful event it could be an
ongoing situation but in any case it's
something painful that the hero or the
character who is going through the arc
believes they don't say if you ask them
they say no that's in the past I'm over
that now it doesn't have any effect on
me but we can see and we will learn that
it affects them greatly because when we
are wounded in real life justice when a
character is wounded or has been wounded
at the start of a movie then that
traumatic event is going to generate a
belief a belief about how the world
works a belief about how people will
behave in certain situations just some
kind of belief it's always a limiting
belief of some in some way connected to
that pain so because his father was so
successful and apparently had a lot of
expectations of him and because he died
before Kathy was too old because he's
not that old even in the movie now that
was his wounding experience in the
belief that came out of that is the
belief that he is not good enough he
can't match up with his father with the
memories father we might not realize
that watching the movie just this far
just in the first act but there are lots
of hints that are going to be drawn
as I will point out in a second but once
the character has this belief that they
in Grain subconsciously they don't
aren't aware that this wound has
anything to do with it then that belief
is going to create a fear a fear of
replicating the pain that they suffered
in the past in a way so if he believes
he's not good enough to match up with
his father then his fear is ever having
to go into a courtroom because as soon
as he actually does a trials you know
whatever hug you say that as soon as he
really becomes a real lawyer and really
defends someone in a court of law
then everybody's going to see that he's
not as good as his father was and that
would be too painful for him so what a
character does to avoid this fear that
grows out of this belief that stems from
this wound in the first place is the
character will create what I call an
identity that's sort of the money idea
in all of this by identity I mean a
persona the character will create a
false self a mask that they present to
the world it's a mask that they're not
aware is a mask they think it's who they
truly are but this will succeed at
protecting them from experiencing the
the pain or the fear that grew out of
that belief that came from the wound a
long time ago so what is Caffey do he
says well if I am NOT gonna meet up with
my if not gonna match my father if it's
gonna be very painful and scary for me
to go into a courtroom I won't do it so
he becomes the great plea bargain er and
there's even a time when Weinberg says
he's considered one of our best
attorneys because he successfully
plea-bargained 42 cases in 60 days or
something like that like that's a claim
to fame which I assume it is but it
shows this guy's identity is I don't go
into a courtroom I just figure out the
best way to plea bargain and I'm very
good at it so I get the best plea I can
for my client so that's the identity he
is fully in in stage 1 and in stage 2
he's going to stay in
identity but he's going to get a glimpse
of what living in what I call his
essence might be the essence being what
would be left if you stripped away this
false self its who the character has the
potential to become and what's his
glimpse his glimpses when he meets
Galloway and then he meets his
defendants because Galloway there's a
line where she says be careful when you
go down to get Moe they're very fanatic
those Marines they're very fanatic and
Weinberg says about what and she says
about being Marines and then when he
meets his clients they say we have a
code in an honor and that's what they
live by and we'll come to a point where
they don't even want a plea bargain
because it would go against their code
this is him getting a glimpse of what
being true to oneself might be he has no
code he has no honor at all he's just
slick what does she call him a you know
a bargain-basement bizarre kind of
hustler as an attorney but that's all
his identity but to be in his essence
would mean he'd have to find a code he
died to find his truth he'd have to be
closer to his defendants who lived that
way and there are lots of hints about
that in stage 2 he goes in and he says
to Galloway she says you've got to
defend them and he says from what I
understand these guys don't need a
lawyer they need a priest making one of
his flippant remarks and her response is
no they need a lawyer and that line will
be repeated many times are you going to
be a lawyer you're gonna be a lawyer
because that's her shorthand for are you
gonna do what you have the potential to
do or are you gonna just fall back on
your usual you know hotshot plea bargain
sort of basis and that brings up one
other thing about Galloway and that is
she is one of his reflection characters
that's just the jargon the term I use
for a character's aligned with the hero
remember the hero has a visible goal
that they want to achieve the reflection
is the character is going to help that
hero achieve the goal she and Weinberg
are both reflections because they're
both there to help him get that reduced
sentence or that acquittal but
the inner journey level it's the
character who is going to point out the
inner conflict to the hero hold the
hero's feet to the fire and every time
the hero is retreating into his safe
identity is going to say to him this
isn't you in this case it's her saying
you need to be a real lawyer and stop
falling back on your usual identity
you